you talk about two cells in terms of how
life is lived the experience self and
remembering self and you describe the
distinction between the two well sure I
mean the there is an aspect of of life
that occasionally you know most of the
time we just live and web experiences
and they're better and they are worse
and it goes on over time and mostly we
forget everything happens we forget most
of what happens then occasionally you
when something ends or different points
you evaluate the past and you form a
memory and the memory is schematic it's
not that you can roll a film of an
interaction you construct in effect the
elements of a story about it about an
episode so there is the experience and
there is a story that is created about
the experience and that's what I call
the remember II so I had the image of
two selves so there is a self that lives
and there is a self that evaluates life
now the paradox and the deep paradox in
that is that we have one system or one
self that does the living but the other
system the remembering self is all we
get to keep and basically
decision-making and and everything that
we do is governed by our memories not by
what actually happened it's it's
governed by by the story that we told
ourselves or by the story that we're
keeping so that's that's the distinction
I mean there's a lot of brilliant ideas
about the pursuit of happiness that come
out of that what are the properties of
happiness which emerge from yourself
there are there are properties of how we
construct stories that are really
important so that I studied a few but
but a couple are really very striking
and one is
that in stories time doesn't matter
there's a sequence of events so there
are highlight or not and and how long it
took you know they lived happily ever
after
and three years later something it time
really doesn't matter and in stories
events matter but time doesn't that that
leads to a very interesting set of
problems because time is all we got to
live I mean you know time is the
currency of life and yet time is not
represented basically in evaluative
memories so that that creates a lot of
paradoxes that I've thought about yeah
they're fascinating but if you were to
[Music]
give advice on how one lives a happy
life
well this and such properties what's the
optimal you know I give up I abandoned
happiness research because I couldn't
solve that problem I couldn't I couldn't
see and in the first place it's very
clear that if you do talk in terms of
those two cells then that what makes the
remembering self happy and what makes
the experiencing self happy are
different things and I I asked the
question of suppose you're planning a
vacation and you're just told that at
the end of the vacation you'll get an
amnesic drugs who remember nothing and
they'll also destroy your your photos so
there'll be nothing would you still go
to the same vacation and and it's it
turns out we go to vacations in large
part to construct memories not to have
experiences but to construct memories
and it turns out that the vacation that
you would want for yourself if you knew
you will not remember is probably not
the same vacation that you will want for
yourself if you will remember
so I have no solution to these problems
but clearly those are big issues and
you've thought about issues you've
talked about sort of how many minutes or
hours you spend about the vacation it's
an interesting way to think about it
because that's how you really experience
the vacation outside the being in it but
there's also a modern I don't know if
you think about this or interact with it
there's a modern way to magnify the
remembering self which is by posting an
Instagram on Twitter on social networks
a lot of people live life for the
picture that you take that you post
somewhere and now thousands of people
sharing and potentially petitioning
millions and then you can relive it even
much more than just those minutes do you
think about that I magnification much
you know I'm too old for social networks
I you know I've never seen Instagram so
I cannot really speak intelligently
about those things I'm just too old but
it's interesting to watch the exact time
described make a very big difference I
mean and it will make it will also make
a difference and that I don't know
whether it's clear that in some ways
the devices that serve us supplants
function so you don't have to remember
phone numbers you don't have you really
don't have to know facts I mean the
number of conversations I'm involved
with when somebody says well let's look
it up so it's it's in a way it's made
conversations well it's it means that
it's much less important to know things
you know it used to be very important to
know things this is changing so the
requirements of that that we have for
ourselves and for other people are
changing because of all those supports
and liquid and I have no idea but
Instagram does connected so well tell
you train you I mean I wish I could just
have the mind remembering self could
enjoy this conversation but I'll get to
enjoy it even more by having what by
watching it and then talking to others
will be about a hundred thousand people
scary's is this to say well listen or
watch this right it changes things
it changes the experience of the world
that you seek out experiences which
could be shared in that way it's in and
I haven't seen it's it's the same
effects that you described and I don't
think the psychology of that
magnification has been described yet
because in your world the sharing then
was appear there was a time when people
read books and you could assume that
your friends had read the same books
that you read so there was kind of
invisible sharing there was a lot of
sharing going on and there was a lot of
assumed common knowledge and you know
that was built in I mean it was obvious
that you had read the New York Times it
was obvious that you'd read the reviews
I mean so a lot was taken for granted
that was she
and you know when they were when there
were three television channels it was
obvious that you'd seen one of them
probably the same so sharing sharing
he's always been always was always there
it was just different
you